TUCKER?
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR THAT DAVID
TAFURI FORMER OBAMA CAMPAIGN
ADVISOR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING
ON.
MOMENTS LIKE THIS ARE SO
INSTRUCTIVE BECAUSE THEY
DIVIDE THE WORLD INTO VERY
CLEAR SECTORS.
YOU SORT OF KNOW WHO IS ON
WHOSE SIDE.
THE RATIONALE HAS CHANGED.
PEOPLE ARE SAY WOULD HE GO
NEED TO FIGHT ISIS BUT
THAT’S NOT REALLY THE POINT.
THE POINT IS TO COUNTER
BALANCE RUSSIA AND IRAN.
AND I’M WONDERING IS THAT A,
OUR GOAL?
B, ACHIEVABLE WITH 2,000
TROOPS IN SYRIA.
LIKE, WHAT ACTUALLY IS THE
GOAL?
I’M LOSING TRACK.
>> WELL, THERE ARE A COUPLE
GOALS.
IT’S TO FIGHT ISIS.
IT’S ALSO TO PUSH BACK ON
IRAN AND ON RUSSIA.
SO, WHAT IS STUNNING ABOUT
THIS DEVELOPMENT IS ALL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S FOREIGN
POLICY ADVISORS AND TOP
MILITARY ADVISORS WERE
AGAINST THIS DECISION.
AND HE REVERSED THEM TODAY.
SUDDENLY.
IN A RASH DECISION.
NOW, THE REASON WHY.
>> Tucker: THEY THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO THINK WE SHOULD
STAY IN AFGHANISTAN, RIGHT?
>> SOME OF THEM ARE -- THE
REASONS ARE DIFFERENT.
LOOK, TRUMP’S TOP POLICY
ADVISOR SAID WE ARE GOING TO
STAY IN SYRIA UNTIL WE HAVE
ONE, ROLLED BACK IRAN.
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED.
TWO, DEFEATED ISIS.
WE HAVE MADE MAJOR PROGRESS
IN FIGHTING ISIS BUT WE
HAVEN’T FULLY DEFEATED THEM.
I WAS IN IRAQ IN OCTOBER.
NOBODY ON THE GROUND IN IRAQ
TELLS ME WE DEFEATED ISIS
THERE ISIS IS EVEN STRONGER
IN SYRIA, STILL.
MOREOVER, ALL OF TRUMP’S
POLICY ADVISORS HAVE SAID WE
SHOULD STAY IN SYRIA UNTIL
THERE IS A POLITICAL
SOLUTION IN SYRIA.
NONE OF THOSE THREE THINGS
HAVE HAPPENED.
THE.
>> Tucker: CAN I STRESS
MAYBE ANOTHER OPTION?
THERE WASN’T ACTUALLY ISIS
IN SYRIA WHEN THE ASSAD
GOVERNMENT CONTROLLED THE
WHOLE COUNTRY, CHRISTIANS
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES, A LOT
OF THEM LIVED IN RELATIVE
PEACE.
NOW THEY ARE HUNTED DOWN AND
MURDERED.
WHY WOULDN’T IT JUST BE THE
SIMPLEST MOST ELEGANT BEST
SOLUTION FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED IF ASSAD MANAGED
HIS ENTIRE COUNTRY AGAIN?
>> BECAUSE YOU ARE IGNORING
THE HISTORY AND DEVELOPMENT
OF THE REVOLUTION IN SYRIA.
THE REVOLUTION IN SYRIA.
>> Tucker: IT JUST HAPPENED
A FEW YEARS AGO.
>> IT HAPPENED IN 2011. IT
HAPPENED ORGANICALLY, RIGHT?
SYRIA WAS IN AUTHORITARIAN
STATE BEFORE THAT TONS OVER
PRESSURE.
>> Tucker: IS THERE
NON-AUTHORITARIAN STATE IN
THAT REGION OTHER THAN
ISRAEL?
>> THERE ARE LESS
AUTHORITARIAN STATES.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE --
JORDAN IS AUTHORITARIAN
STATE.
CRITICIZE THE KING AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> YOU CANNOT COMPARE JORDAN
TO SYRIA.
YOU CANNOT COMPARE SYRIA TO
IRAQ.
>> Tucker: I’M SAYING
AUTHORITARIAN JUSTIFIES
NOTHING.
THEY ARE ALL AUTHORITARIAN.
>> THIS WAS ORGANIC
REVOLUTION IT STARTED BY THE
SYRIAN PEOPLE.
MAJORITY OF WHOM ARE SUNNI
ARAB.
THEY STOOD UP AGAINST ASSAD.
HE CHOSE, RATHER THAN
RECONCILE WITH THEM.
HE CHOSE TO MOW THEM DOWN
AND SLAUGHTER TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF INNOCENT,
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
THAT’S HOW THE REVOLUTION
BEGAN.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT DEFENDING
ASSAD’S CHARACTER.
I’M SAYING.
>> GOOD, YOU SHOULDN’T.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT SYRIAN.
I DON’T WORK FOR ASSAD.
I’M AMERICAN.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT’S BEST
FOR US.
IF YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
CHAOS AND THE HUGE REFUGEE
PROBLEMS CAUSED BY THIS
CIVIL WAR, AND BY THE
EMERGENCE OF ISIS, AGAIN,
ABETTED BY THE CIVIL WAR.
THEN, WHY WOULDN’T YOU LONG
FOR THE DAYS WHERE
CHRISTIANS COULD LIVE
UNMOLESTED IN SYRIA UNDER
THIS AUTHORITARIAN ASSAD?
I’M TOTALLY MISSING IT.
WHAT AM I MISSING?
>> THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
CAUSE MORE REFUGEES.
OKAY?
NORTHEASTERN SYRIA RIGHT NOW
IS SECURE.
THE REASON IT’S SECURE IS
BECAUSE OF THE GREAT WORK BY
OUR U.S. SPECIAL FORCES
WORKING WITH THE FDF.
THE LOCAL SYRIAN AND
MODERATE SUNNI FORCES ON THE
GROUND.
THEY SECURED IT LESS
REFUGEES COMING FROM THAT
AREA.
PEOPLE CAN SAY THERE
PEACEFULLY NOT GETTING
BOMBED BY ASSAD AND WHEN WE
PULL OUT IT IS GOING TO
CAUSE A MASSIVE WAVE OF
SYRIAN REFUGEES, AGAIN,
FORCES ARE GOING TO GO IN
AND SLAUGHTER THE FORCES
THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH ON THE GROUND.
ASSAD FORCES, IRANIAN SHE A
MILITIA FORCES AND POSSIBLY
EVEN RUSSIA FORCES.
>> Tucker: SO WE’RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT?
THIS IS HALFWAY AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE HAVE CRISES LIKE
VENEZUELA’S RIGHT THERE.
MEXICO HAS PROBABLY AS MANY
MURDERS AS SYRIA.
NOT CLOSE, RIGHT?
SO I’M JUST SAYING THERE ARE
A LOT OF THINGS GOING ON.
WE HAVE A MORAL OBLIGATION
TO KEEP 2,000 AMERICAN
TROOPS IN THIS COUNTRY
AROUND THE WORLD BECAUSE,
WHY?
I’M CONFUSED.
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE
ARE THERE ALREADY.
AND IT’S SUCCESSFUL.
SO WHY PULL OUT?
WE ALSO DO HAVE SOME
OBLIGATION OF FORCES ON THE
GROUND WHO FOUGHT BRAVELY
ALONGSIDE US.
MOREOVER, THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT US BECAUSE ISIS WILL
COME BACK.
AND IF WE DON’T HAVE FORCES
ON THE GROUND TO MONITOR
ISIS AND TO CONTINUE TO
COMBAT ISIS, ISIS WILL COME
BACK -- ISIS ARE SWORN
ENEMIES OF THE U.S.
THEY WANT TO KILL AMERICANS.
AND WHEN THEY BECOME
STRONGER IN SYRIA THEY WILL
STRIKE OUT.
YOUR VIEWERS SHOULD WORRY
ABOUT THEIR OWN SECURITY
BECAUSE OF THIS DECISION.
>> Tucker: THERE ARE A LOT
OF REASONS TO WORRY ABOUT
OUR OWN SECURITY.
A LOT.
MANY.
AND OUR MENTAL HEALTH AND
OUR ECONOMY AND OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
A LOT OF THINGS TO WORRY
ABOUT.
BUT, BY THE STANDARDS THAT
YOU HAVE JUST ARTICULATED
LIKE WE ARE NEVER GOING TO
LEAVE THERE OR AFGHANISTAN
OR ANY PLACE THAT WE HAVE
BEEN FOR MORE THAN EIGHT
MONTHS.
>> I WOULD SAY WE WERE NEVER
GOING TO LEAVE THERE WE HAVE
TO SEE PROGRESS ON THE
GROUND.
WE HAVE TO SEE FULL DEFEAT
OF ISIS.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
>> WE HAVE TO SEE POLITICAL
PROCESS.
REVOLUTION IN SYRIA.
THERE OUGHT TO BE A
DEMOCRACY IN SYRIA.
>> Tucker: WHO CARES ABOUT
THAT.
>> WHO CARES ABOUT
DEMOCRACY?
>> Tucker: WHAT I CARE ABOUT
IS WHAT HAPPEN WHAT IS
HAPPENING TO THE CHRISTIANS
THERE.
NOBODY CARES.
EVADE IRAQ.
HUGE CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY.
>> WHO ARE KILLING THE
CHRISTIANS IN IRAQ?
>> OF COURSE, BUT I’M JUST
SAYING WHY DON’T WE MAKE.
>> ISLAMIC MILITANTS ARE
KILLING CHRISTIANS IN JUAN
IRAN.
>> Tucker: MAKE IT EXPLICIT
CONCERN OF THE TO KILL WE
DON’T LET THEM.
>> IN CONCERN OF THE U.S. TO
PROTECT ALL MINORITIES IN
SYRIA AND IRAQ WHICH THE
CHRISTIAN MINORITIES ARE
IMPORTANT PART OF.
>> Tucker: THEY DON’T SEEM